on va vous donner un petit medley de
Jean-Baptiste Guégan
usurpateur est-ce qu'il se sert de
Johnny Hallyday où est-ce que il fait du
bien aux gens tout simplement on en
débat après
[Musique]
que je t'aime
retourner la page
une fois
un
âge pour la dernière
saison ma belle vie de
il en est
feu qui m'a vu
les ingénieurs pas dans la vie
je t'envoie je m'ennuie
[Applaudissements]
je reviendrai pas
il chantait dans les petites salles il a
une voix incroyable maintenant il chante
il fait des gros il a fait des élites il
fait 50% de ses chansons 50% des
chansons de Johnny les fans viennent
surtout pour ça et ça commence à faire
débat parce que parce qu'en fait il y en
a qui disent maintenant mais tu vis sur
la bête c'est pas c'est pas tes chansons
évidemment comme de la famille ça se
déteste si Sylvie Vartan le défend à
mort également le fils aussi le défend
mais Laetitia elle elle dit je ne suis
pas sûr que ça aurait pu être Johnny je
ne veux pas vous mentir ça me met mal à
l'aise je n'irai pas le voir en concert
et en septembre 2021 donc elle préparait
la cérémonie la mémoire de son mari
Johnny sur France 2 et elle a refusé qui
viennent alors qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez très partagé en fait c'est simple
Laetitia dès qu'il y a un euro en
rapport avec Johnny on revient pas dans
ces caisses elle réagit et elle réagit
toujours comme ça ça fait cinq ans
on me demande mon avis
très bien j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur le
sur le dos
je suis d'accord avec Laeticia Hallyday
je trouve que moi ce mec que j'ai
découvert comme vous il a un talent fou
il chante comme Johnny c'est sosie
vocale ça me met à l'aise ça me met mal
à l'aise d'entendre la voix de Johnny
dans un corps qui est un corps d'un type
que bizarre enfin je mec et ça me met à
l'aise ouais cultive tout l'univers les
freins les Gims enfin il y a tout du
Johnny et je comprends que ça puisse
déranger tu sais qu'il arrive pas au
concert entendre quelqu'un qu'elle se et
vous savez ce que j'ai arrêté dans les
concerts c'est que les gens qui viennent
les fans de Johnny quand ils chantent
noir c'est noir ils sont comme un fou et
quand ils sentent d'Armor voilà les
Côtes-d'Armor sa chanson qu'il a écrit
en Bretagne tout le coup il s'en foutent
donc c'est un jeu il a sorti là il en
est à son troisième album le premier de
l'avoir vu à 300000 le deuxième en plein
covid plus de 100000 donc là c'est pas
vrai ces chansons plaisent à son public
évidemment moins que les chansons de
Johnny ça c'est sûr ça c'est sûr alors
Isabelle le pense que ce n'est pas un
usurpateur moi je l'ai découvert quand
il a fait la première fois la France a
un incroyable talent mais il y en a une
qui connaît très bien de Johnny qui
était ami avec lui c'est Hélène Ségara
et Maria James connaissait aussi très
bien Johnny quand
mais c'est pas c'est pas un imitateur
c'est juste il sait quelque chose
d'incroyable qui est totalement Apple
ils étaient en larmes et honnêtement moi
aussi parce que ce mec il ne cultive
rien de Johnny
comme ça il est comme ça il a il a les
mêmes failles que Johnny
que Johnny il y a quelque chose de
totalement
en tout cas des gens qui chantent du
jogging il y en a dans toute la France
on a partout sauf que d'habitude on se
fout de leur gueule parce qu'ils sont
mauvais ça passe en confession intime là
lui il a un don tellement exceptionnel
que du coup c'est plus dans les dans les
rubriques de de d'ironie
de ce côté là moi ce que je trouve un
peu dur je donne mon avis c'est si il
donne du bonheur aux gens bien sûr ça
peut là vous êtes tous sur
batteurs alors oui mais oui mais vous
trouvez les urbateurs Christopher et
Sophie moi je trouve ils ont pas tort
c'est vrai qu'il a une grande voie voilà
et c'est un grand artiste etc mais c'est
vrai que lorsqu'on le regarde même sa
tenue de la croix avec la boucle la
ceinture qui rappelle Johnny et si on
regarde bien il a commencé voilà même la
moto s'il a commencé à exploser c'est
après la mort de Johnny et pas avant si
les gens vont le voir avec ça leur fait
du bien il faisait des concerts Isabelle
ça fait deux semaines tu prends beaucoup
la parole tu laisses pas la main là tu
es chez toi ah je te le redis ah c'est
les amours boum oui effectivement
pas de couteau j'aime beaucoup Cyril je
l'embrasse très fort
[Rires]
on est tellement heureux la semaine
prochaine d'avoir Ludivine
non mais je suis d'accord avec vous
Mathieu effectivement ça fait plaisir
aux gens pourquoi pas on s'en fout le
seul truc c'est que il cultive ça et il
y a un truc moi qui me dérange c'est que
Johnny c'est une star mais c'est une
vraie star donc normalement une star
c'est inimitable c'est unique il y a
quelque chose d'authentique chez Johnny
Hallyday que les gens l'adorent et le
fait de voilà d'imiter j'aime pas
tellement le terme d'usure pasteur mais
le fait de se servir de ça voilà de
Johnny Hallyday etc de tout son univers
je peux comprendre Laetitia Hallyday je
peux comprendre que ça puisse la
déranger il y a un côté un peu gênant
effectivement il surf non mais je pense
que juste on va arrêter le cul je pense
que oui
pourquoi parce que je suis arrivé de
Johnny au début j'avoue que ça m'aider
non mais franchement je comprends les
fans au départ qui se raccrochaient à ça
mais à un moment donné j'avoue que ça
devient gênant parce que du coup on
réalise qu'en fait ben on fait pas le
deuil sur lui et lui c'est ce qui
cultive en fait et d'ailleurs Isa
excuse-moi mais il s'est fait connaître
grâce à qui grâce à une chanson de
Johnny si tu le connais aujourd'hui
c'est grâce à qui c'est
Johnny il a commencé en chantant du
bracelet hein mais
[Applaudissements]
un petit truc un petit truc important
parce qu'on ne dit pas on parle de
Laetitia qui est contre et comme par
hasard David Hallyday Sylvie Vartan a
sûrement Laura sont totalement rares
sont et Laura sont à fond derrière
Jean-Baptiste
de son ex-femme et de son fils ils ont
autre chose totalement à fond il dit
qu'il soit à fond
en même temps mais c'était pas
non c'est pas parce que tu fais ça alors
pendant la parole que ça passe aussi
[Applaudissements]
quand tu regardes la télé je te promets
c'est très dérangeant t'entends tout tu
vois pas tu vois on a fait donc
doucement et on finit avec ce sujet je
suis confuse mais c'est moi qui le
connais le mieux et le terme qu'on peut
pas utiliser en parlant de lui c'est
vraiment usurpateur vous pouvez dire que
ça vous plaît pas vous pouvez dire que
vous pensez que c'est un imitateur vous
avez pas le droit de dire c'est pasteur
parce que usure pasteur il y a
l'intention de nuire et c'est tout sauf
ça on arrête avec ce sujet moi mon avis
moi seulement c'est si ça fait plaisir
je sais publique qui a raison aussi
j'irai pas le voir s'il paye pour aller
le voir c'est que ça leur fait plaisir
si tu comprends pas les débats moi je
comprends pas les débats mais bon